they're very muscle grafts please call
you must be interpretation which brings
our planet acid
there's
so
okay o people coming in
nah
right so here we are at the fine lecture
in the series you're the survivors so
what I want that's right yes I'll be
issuing certificates at the end of this
so in this lecture I want to tell you
about some relatively recent work on
combinatorial optimization problems and
relation to define ability which you
know building up a little bit on some of
the things we've done so i'll start with
a quick review so we've been talking
about tools for analyzing the expressive
power of logic over finite structures
and we use these in the last lecture to
investigate logics for polynomial time
okay and so in particular one thing we
did last time was look at this notion of
CK equivalents for fixed values of K
equivalents in the counting logic would
k variables and that was a I mean use
that to show that solve ability of
systems of linear equations over the two
element field is not definable in fixed
my logic with counting and but still
fixed by Dragic with counting is a
powerful a natural fragment of P but
it's not all of P and in some sense what
we're going to do what we're going to do
in this lecture is say something more
about both the power and the limits of
this in the context of combinatorial
optimization problems okay
so in particular FPC can't express the
systems of systems of linear equations
over a finite field and now once we sort
of knew this we started to look at
linear algebra I said linear algebra or
finite fields is an interesting place to
look at the limits of the expressive
power fixed point with tempting I'm not
going to say much more about finite
fields beyond this slide but I just
wanted to say when you start working on
this you can show that matrix
multiplication over finite fields is
definable now what does this mean if you
have ordered structures everything in
polynomial time is definable in fixed
point logic so we really mean matrices
that are unordered and i'll make this
precise what that means in a little bit
you can say you know non singularity
inverse of a matrix i think address you
have this in a paper at least for the
element field or maybe generally so
there's a lot of linear algebra that you
can already do in fixed point with
counting in this paper where we
introduce rank logics we also show that
the the reason we chose the rank
operator is because things like
determinant in fact the characteristic
polynomial of matrix are all definable
in fixed point law with counting but
still you can't you to solve ability of
systems of linear equation then it
follows that you can't define the rank
of a matrix okay so this seemed to focus
on a particular property that you can't
define and that's what led us to define
a logical fixed point with rank and look
at the expressive power but that's a
direction I'm not going to pursue in
this talk instead I want to I just
wanted to stress that this is
specifically about finite fields if you
go to the rational field all of this is
still definable right you can still do
matrix multiplication and I'll explain
in the next side or two what what
exactly this means you can define you
know the invertible matrices you can
define the inverse of a matrix you can
define the characteristic polynomial the
determinant but you can also define the
rank of a matrix and you can test
systems of equations for solubility all
of this is in b arky homes
PhD thesis from 2010 which is yeah I
mean sort of comprehensively covered
this but what I thought what a point now
is that this fact also follows from a
result which we proved with matt
anderson and b arky home which shows a
says that the optimization of linear
programs with you know rational
coefficients can also be expressed in
fixed point with counting I put 2015
here that's the the journal paper
appeared in December yes that's right so
there is I mean the system of equation
is represented as a finite structure and
there's no formal of the logic which is
true in this structure if and only is it
has a solution okay so I want to tell
you a little bit about this a result to
start with so what first of all let's I
mean we're talking about finite
structures so let's turn everything into
finite structures to start with so what
is a rational number for a rational
number for me is given by a sign and two
integers numerator and sorry two
positive integers suppose strictly
speaking an can be 0 but D can't ok and
we're going to think of this as a finite
structure as formals we have a domain B
which is linearly ordered and we have
three ulery relations on B which
represent the sign the numerator and the
denominator ok so let us think of this
as a binary representation of a rational
number so the sign will just sake is if
it's empty it's one if it's non empty
it's minus 1 and these just called the
binary representation of these numbers
seeing this as an ordered collection of
its bit positions ok so this is just a
it's a linearly ordered finite structure
right that's what a rational number is
for us
and since it's ordered we know that
anything any polynomial time operation
on these is going to be definable in
fixpoint logic so we can assume that we
have operations in FPC for doing all of
ordinary arithmetic on rational numbers
okay structure is vulnerable yes well I
mean so I'm saying I'm adopting this as
a representation now you can I'll leave
it to you you can easily define a
representation of two rational numbers
in one structure and a formula that that
defines their some you know or or the
product right okay so what does it mean
to be defined there is a formula section
okay maybe I mean strictly speaking okay
so given a structure which is a pair of
rational numbers that's stress a
structure like that will basically have
s1 s2 and one end to be 1 and D 2 right
that's a pair of fractional numbers and
I just say we can define
let me call this pie for product let's
say
is pi n pi be a triple of formulas a
fixed point with hardening which
interpreted in any such structure will
give you the sign the numerator and the
denominator of the product ok let's
human b has enough bits to represent the
product until and there's a fixed triple
of such formulas a fixed interpretation
of which will define product and sum and
any reasonable operation you want ok
now I'm going to talk about vectors and
matrices of rational numbers and
crucially well I think the rational
number is represented by an ordered
structure the order is an inevitable
there a vector is not necessarily an
ordered structure so vector index by set
i right we represent as a structure
whose domain is a domain of bit
positions as we had before and a
separate domain representing the index
at I and the I can be an unordered set
so we have an order on the bit positions
and now the sign numerator and
denominator our binary relations which
relate the index to these bit positions
so fix an index value in I and these
give you the sets in be representing the
sign the numerator and denominator of
the eyes vector okay and similarly a
rational matrix now you can take take
the next step will have as domain the
two in the two index sets and B and s N
and D which are ternary relations which
relate to positions inj and give you the
rational entry in position i J okay
multi structures where I and J are
distinguished that's right so so imma
sue you you can if you want have a
single universe and Ian relations I J
and B and yeah I'm assuming in the logic
I can tell whether something is an eye
or a j.o.b right exactly that's the
important thing I mean it's I and J
where ordered sets and again everything
that's polynomial time becomes definable
but this is now you might say why are we
restricting ourselves to unordered
matrices but there is a good reason for
this which hopefully I will become here
and i'll try and stress it when we get
to that point okay
so as an example actually well I think
we are at a point weighted graphs other
are the sort of object you might want to
say something about and weighted graphs
are very naturally I mean naturally
arise in optimization problems you have
a graph and the the edges carry weights
which are say rush into your way to
rational weights or something like this
and like with everything we've done so
far we don't want to assume or an order
on the vertices of the graph or or on
the edges of the graph or anything like
that so what is a weighted graph we'll
think of it so a vertex set with
rational weights is simply whatever I
said here non- rational weights on the
edges so right well this is a universal
vertices and again bit positions and we
have weight relations which associate
with every pair of vertices the
numerator and denominator as a subset of
the bit positions okay this is just a ma
this is simply exactly this situation
where I happens to be the set V cross B
honor honor autograph on a given graph
on over a given vertex set V ok one way
does it present bias traction but now
you get a weighted graph yes so the
point was what yeah so I'm sorry I'm not
being very clear then so as a single
rational number is represented by unary
relations on this on the set of bit
positions which is a linearly ordered
set now a vector of or or a weighted
graph we want to associate a set in
unary relation for a numerator with
every pair of vertices right and so we
have a ternary relation which will
basically think of this with every pair
of vertices it associates a subset of B
that gives the numerator associated with
that pair and another ternary relation
which every for every pair of vertices
gives us a set of
b which gives us the denominator
associated with that pair right so yeah
I was just trying to go through the
step-by-step so so I think now it's sort
of clear how we represent rational
matrices as finite structures and we can
now sensibly asked questions about
define ability and the particular define
ability questions we want to ask
absolutes say linear programming because
I mean I sort of said at the beginning
that we show that optimization of linear
programs is definable in fixed point
with counting linear program is of
course an important algorithmic tool and
it's to solve for a large variety of
optimization problems and I'm going to
go on to look at a few we know it is
polynomial-time solvable by result going
back to catch an 1980 so let's just
define the set up so a linear program
for us is given by a set of constraints
over a set of variables and crucially in
the kinds of applications we're
interested in these variables in these
constraints don't come with any order on
them right there are ordered sets each
constraint is a vector of rationals
indexed by the variables and an
additional Russian all so basically we
think of this as I think I have it here
yes right basically that linear
constraint 8a c transpose x x is less
than or equal to B C for every
constraint see so given such a
constraints there's a simple decision
problem is it solvable is it feasible
and that's just saying that is there a
vector of rationals which satisfies all
of them simultaneously the optimization
problem in general has this along with
an objective function which is given by
another vector right it's a linear
objective function and we want to find
the maximum value let's say of the
objective function over the set of
let's add a fresh smells witnessing the
feasibility
and what we show I know I realize this
has changed 2013 was the conference
paper but what we show is that this
problem the feasibility problem and the
corresponding optimization problem are
expressible in fixed point with counting
ok so we can define if explain good
counting formula which a sentence which
will decide feasibility right given the
set of constraints it will determine
whether it's it will be satisfied in
there if and only if that's sort of
constraint is feasible and it expresses
optimization in this sense in that there
is a there will be a tuple of formulas
which interpreted in a linear program
will give you the optimum value ok
assuming there is one yeah so I mean we
will we have to define it carefully
essentially there is an interpretation
which I mean you find some code you know
put this to be minus one or something
which says that it's infeasible freedom
of our unbound exactly so so we
distinguish the cases and we shall
construct the formula which you know
gives you all possible values is not
over finite fields but that's that that
was a distinction I was making at the
beginning we proved that over finite
fields it's not but already in BR keys
thesis he showed that over the rational
field it was and this is in some sense a
generalization because it shows that you
know optimization of linear programs is
already definable so this is a stronger
define ability result then feasibility
of linear equations but the key
distinction is this works out with a
rational field it does not work over
finite fields
so the classic algorithm for both is the
same therefore equations i mean is well
that's right so the I mean Gaussian
elimination algorithm we don't know how
to implement we're going to implement
the ellipsoid method right okay so
that's the way which turns out it is
something we can do in here and that
doesn't work or finite fields and what
does yeah it requires a new systems of
equations over to professionals yeah
peak of this could be he actually shows
how to define the rank of the matrix and
this depends upon a characterization of
rank which really works only on fields
of characteristic 0 so it's that was a
different line okay sorry the Gaussian
elimination doesn't work exactly right
so I am a little bit confused here you
try to express the decision problem
let's look at the decision problem
deciding this inequalities right yes
that's really something show if you can
express this by itself in FPC
automatically because of the point
normal time because fec is contained in
will be time right gives you what you
know me I'm that's right so yeah so what
doesn't you say you did enjoyed al good
oh well ok but the question is yes how
do we construct this FPC formula right
but to show its definable we need to
construct this FPC formula we encode the
ellipsoid algorithm right i mean those
are our formula is an encoding of the
algorithm or adapted yes sir what is
just because kachchi this all of the
time to spawn
that's right no no I I think Falcone was
asking whether we had found another
polynomial time algorithm a different
polynomial time algorithm we encode the
ellipsoid method where's the gal see
doesn't work because you don't have
worry you don't have an order that's
right exactly ok konshens algorithm is
it or developer but a prop effectively
approximates to arbitrary desired
precision your and then you need to do a
kind of a rounding rules rounding inside
FPC well what you can do is the
following and maybe if I should go on
because I i mean III think you're just
pre-empting with the sir i mean i don't
know that i have the exact answer on my
slides but i think the question will
make sense once i start talking about
the ellipsoid method okay right so what
is the ellipsoid method moving on we
have a set of linear constraints they
determine a polytope I mean this is in
two dimensions because that's all those
are available to me on the slide but
this is so this would be one with let's
say five linear constraints and it
determines a bounded polytope so the
ellipsoid method sort of works by we
want to find a point inside this
polytope we start somewhere may as well
start at the origin and from the because
all of these are given by rational
coefficients from the rationals looking
at the largest size of the denominator
you can clear you can calculate a bound
on an ellipsoid centered at the origin
with must contain the this polytope all
right or well if it's bounded or
so we start start the origin and
calculate the ellipsoid now we can test
whether this origin is in the polytope
if it is of course we're done since it's
not we choose one of the linear
constraints that it violates all right
so it's on the wrong side of this line
you calculate a new point by projecting
or you know growth moving orthogonal e
to the hyperplane which which you picked
f around this you can calculate a new
ellipsoid which still contains the
polytope but is substantially smaller in
volume and this substantially smaller is
what guarantees convergence because it
says that in at most polynomially many
steps now this is polynomial not in a
number of constraints but in a bit
precision of these of these constraints
you're guaranteed that if you still are
not in the polytope your ellipsoid will
have shrunk so small that you will know
that the polytope is empty okay and
that's the that's the sort of
approximation in rounding you're talking
about and so here it's crucial that this
thing works in polynomial time not just
in the number of constraints or anything
but in the size of this B which we made
explicit a part of the structure okay so
so in some sense you don't have to do
that rounding explicitly okay but um I'm
I'm not sure if I 16 questions
to make the so the initial pollito needs
to be full dimensional yes very very
very good point and we have to address
this yes okay the ball the point
creatures making is because this this
thing about half the volume if the
polytope is not full dimensional for
instance it says it's a two-dimensional
polytope inside a three-dimensional
space it has zero volume to start with
right and so this this thing doesn't
work but yeah we love you we need you to
overcome that and I'll say something
about that okay but at the moment I've
just described sort of the rough outline
of the ellipsoid method all the
calculations you need to do you can
implement at FPC you know because all of
this sort of matrix manipulation that I
talked about you know algebraic
manipulations of unordered matrices this
is the sort of stuff I said on the first
slide we all know how to do the one
thing we don't know how to do is going
back over here I said when this is not
in there you choose one of the
constraints that it violates but
choosing is what we can't do right the
set of constraints is an unordered set
and you can't pick one out of it in in
the logic
okay but the great thing about the
ellipsoid method is robust enough that
is you each step if you don't actually
have to pick one of the constraints all
you need is some hyperplane that
separates the polytope from your current
point so for instance view right i mean
it doesn't have to be one of the
constraints it could be this and in
particular just take the set of all the
constraints that are violated and add
them up by linearity this is also a
separating hyperplane right so no choice
involved you just add them up and it
works okay
but will that reduce the volume yes via
now that this I mean I mean the absurd
method is very robust as far as this the
sort of thing is concerned almost
anything will write this could have been
another constraint anyway without
affecting the power zone yes yeah so um
okay so so but as I said now the episode
method is is very robust and they can do
much more than this in that actually
many applications al absurd method you
aren't even given this constraint matrix
explicitly it's somehow implicitly given
by some kind of structure all you really
require is that from this structure and
given a candidate point you can
determine in polynomial time a
hyperplane that separates your point
from the polytope right you don't
explicitly have a description of the
polytope in terms of a set of
constraints right you all you need to do
is to be able to calculate a separating
hyperplane given any point right that's
what we call a separation Oracle in
particular the representation may be
compact in that the number of facets of
this polytope could be exponentially
large so express right in it out
explicitly would be exponential size in
the size of the structure you actually
have ok and what we show is that as long
as the separation Oracle is definable in
FPC then the optimization problem can be
solved in FPC so this whole thing works
if the separation Oracle is given by
some FBC formula so what is it formally
what do we mean so a representation of a
class of polytopes is some relational
vocabulary and a mapping which takes
tell structures to the polytopes in p
which is isomorphism invariant okay so
we don't care it I the one we aren't
putting no other conditions on this so
it's just some way of representing
polytopes structures in an isomorphism
invariant fashion and then a separation
Oracle we say a separation or Oracle for
this representation is definable if
there is an FPC formula and again I
think maybe with a nod to yonex I really
should say an FPC interpretation it's
generally a tippler formulas
which given a structure right add a
vector now this vector stiffel of
variables we assume that this tuple of
variables is it is given in the
structure determines either that this is
in the polytope or it defines in this
sense a hyperplane that separates the
polytope from from this week ok so this
FPC formula acts on a structure which
encodes the polytope in some compact
fashion possibly and a structure which
represents a vector and as an
interpretation defines a hyperplane
right or gives you the answer it's
solved ok
now I'm going to say this a bit quickly
and this is partly you know addressing
your your issue of Earth polytopes of
zero volume
the way this were the way this whole
thing works is the structure a we assume
okay the variables are represented
explicitly as a set in the structure
let's say so the number of facets of
this polar talk may be exponential and
may not be represented explicitly
the variables form an unordered said but
we can construct a sort of partial order
on them using the separation Oracle so
initially you start with all the
variables are kind of AA not
distinguished from each other you start
with the or point at the origin and you
if you get a separating hyperplane from
the polytope essentially this hyperplane
will distinguish some variables from
others is there distinguish some
dimensions from others in the in the in
the space and that constructs a sort of
a partial industry it makes a certain
distinction between some of the
dimensions at any point we can we have a
projection which defines
my eye I should have put more on the
slide but so at any point we have the
set of variables and we have an
equivalence relation on the variables
meaning those are variables which we
haven't been able to distinguish it and
this equal it's actually an ordered
equivalence relation so we have an
ordering on the equivalence classes this
defines a projection onto a space of
smaller dimension which is basically the
quotient of this quotient of the set of
dimensions under this equivalence
relation ok and we can define a way of
projecting the polytope from this larger
dimension space to the smaller
dimensional space in a way that
preserves feasibility or if it fails in
the sense that it might happen that it
doesn't preserve field feasibility but
if it does then the separation Oracle
will pop out and refine this equivalence
relation further ok this is a bit hand
wavy i know but i think it's i'll have
to refer you to what we can discuss this
further for details if you want ok and
this kind of gets around this lack of
full dimension because where we end up
working in a space which is quotient it
and so as a smaller dimension and we
keep increasing the dimension until we
hit the dimension of the polytope
effectively or or I mean we don't
actually have to because of though if
the polytope as well has automorphisms
we might actually work in a smaller
dimensional space right but it kind of
makes it work ok so now the application
I want to show you is graph matching
right so remember that in a graph a
matching is a set of edges which is so
that every vertex is incident to at most
one edge in em and we saw that we can't
define the existence of a perfect
matching in fixed point logic in the
absence of counting right that was a
simple example with bipartite graphs
actually for bipartite graphs we've
known for a while but it is definable in
fixed point with counting this is in
paper by Andre us with urien Sal
ranchera I mean this is all you know
quite a this was a quite a clever
construction basically showing that if
you refine the bipartite graph by K
equivalents for suitably suitable large
k I think three is probably enough by ck
equivalence and then you throw in all
the edges between equivalent but between
equivalence classes you don't create a
matching if there wasn't one already and
then the and then it becomes different
you know you can check in this graph ok
but that was for bipartite graphs and
for general graphs it was open since
then and we're able to do this now by
basically showing that effectively the
optimization problem of finding a
maximum matching in a weighted graph
coded suitably as a linear program we
get something for which the separation
Oracle is definable in fixed point with
counting ok not you finally nephew in
FTC up there so this sorry this is not
definable in FP yeah we did this we
showed right we saw this as an example
and in sp see where I'm going to prove
it is definable by showing but
essentially if you code it up suitably
as a linear program we can express the
separation Oracle for it in FPC ok well
we got the idea the admins polytope is
what we use yes yes
so this is the admins polytope so the
problem is we're given a graph along
with the way weights on the edges right
a positive or non-negative rational
leads then the problem of finding a
maximum weight matching is given by this
polytope now note this polytope is of
exponential has exponentially many
facets so we don't want to write this
out explicitly okay so what is it so why
is the set of variables in this linear
program and we are going to say maximize
the weights of these subject to certain
constraints so this just says you're
only picking edges right this is the
adjacency matrix of the graph I suppose
yes ah you're assigning a you're picking
each edge with zero or more weight i
suppose it's strictly speaking you you
know at most once as well and this is
the key point I mean and then I'm not
going to prove it you but this is what
Edmund shows that if you throw in this
exponential set of constraints which
basically says for every odd set of
vertices you say that the set of edges
you pick from among the set W has weight
at most half of W minus 1 then do you
know then this actually defines the what
should I say the convex hull of the
perfect of the maximum weight matching
sorry in the convex hull of the
matchings and so maximizing over this
gives you the maximum weight matching ok
so this is as I said this is an this is
an exponential size linear program you
don't want to write it out explicitly is
exponential in the size of the graph
that we start with but what we can show
is that there is a FPC
interpretation which given just the
weighted graph and a candidate vector
right so the assignment of weights to
the edges will give you a separation
separating hyperplane if it's not a
matching or tell you it is matching its
etc right so this this gives us the
separation Oracle we need and as a
consequence there's an FPC formula that
can define the size of the maximum
matching in a graph nope you can't write
down a formula that defines an actual
matching because this is not invariant
under isomorphisms right a click for
instance contains exponentially many
matchings all isomorphic to each other
there's no way you can pick out one
there's no way you can even define them
all right but all what you can do is it
get the value how big is the matching
that pops out of this I mean it's kind
of in a sense the FPC formula will give
you a solution to the to the system of
linear equations but that's the solution
will be not a matching but a linear
combination of matchings right but but
but this is the thing so unlike I mean
the solution we get is not necessarily a
vertex of the polytope that's right it
can be somewhere on the face of the
political and so in this case it's not
going to be a matching in general it'll
be some linear combination of maximum
matchings because because up to
isomorphism we can't distinguish them so
in some sense we'll get a linear
combination of all of them well yeah
so I see so this in linear programming
there's the standard trick that if you
get an optimal solution you can convert
it to an optimal basic feasible solution
by going to the nearby basis so that
part I Part you can't do in 6.2
accounting because that breaks
isomorphism sis okay so now if minutes
remaining I want to give you a sort of
more recent application of this to to
constraint satisfaction problems we've
been thinking about so to introduce this
i'm going to introduce well i've just
given it a name counting with save me
i'm a class of structures to classify
nice structures which may and with any
class of cyanide structures any what i
call the property at the beginning of
the course we associate a function i'll
call it the counting width from numbers
numbers which is for every n gives you
the least k so that some formula theta
of ck defines exactly the structures in
this class with at most n elements right
so note take any class of structures if
I bound the size of structures to n i
can define the structures in this class
with the first order formula right
because I'd only up to isomorphism
finitely many I bound it n in fact I can
do it with the form for a sort of
formula using no more than n variables
okay so i want to say well let's count
the number of variables we need but
rather than first order logic i'm going
to allow counting so i'm looking at the
number of variables you need and
counting logic to define it to define
the structures of size at most n in the
class c okay i'm treating this as a sort
of measure of the complexity of the task
it's always less at most n as i said you
can always write down the formula of had
balls to n variables right
well it's always at most n if the class
is definable in fixed point we're
counting is in fact a constant that was
what we said last time that any formula
fixed point with counting is invariable
sorry is invariant under K equivalent
for some fixed value of K and that from
that you can see that from for a bounded
size structure it translates into a
formula of ck ok so for classes
definable f in FP see this is bounded by
a constant the thing that I showed you
last time I use these toroidal grids to
show you that solving systems of linear
equations over the 12 midfield is not
definable it actually immediately gives
you a bound lower bound the square root
of n on the size of this function
because basically I constructed a
structure of size order K squared where
you know solvability is not doable with
in CKD it was K squared it turns out you
can improve this lower bound from square
root of n 2 Omega n by instead of these
explicit order grids you consider expand
your graphs or something like this I'm
not going into that just I want I want
to say that the lower bound can be
improved to linear right so it's pretty
much as bad as it gets because this
function is always bounded by hand up
above ok what does this have to do with
constraint satisfaction problems folk
Yun has kind of introduced constraint
satisfaction problems in his in his
lectures usually you describe a
constraint language as given by some
finite domain D and a correction of
relations on D which is what we just
call a finite relational structure when
the language is finite and so I'm going
to restrict ourselves to finite
languages for now right so this is just
a finite relation structures the way
we've been thinking about it and this
problem this csv gamma is the problem of
deciding given a set of constraints
whether it is satisfiable and what is
the constraint the constraint is a
temple of variables along with the
relation r from ghana
right and so we to satisfy me it is to
find an assignment of values to this in
the domain D so that this tuple of
values is in the relation R right so
that's what a constraint is a set of
constraints can therefore be seen simply
as another finite relational structure
you take the set of all variables that
appear you take the relations that
appear on them and then the problem is
simply that of homomorphism decide
whether there's a homomorphism from this
incident to this fixed finite relational
structure right so this as [ __ ] you and
said CSP is just the homomorphism
problem for finite structures ok
now there's been a lot of work on
classifying csps [ __ ] you mentioned that
non to color ability is definable so to
color ability which can be expressed as
a constraint satisfaction problem right
the domain is just the two colors and
the relation you have is that of this
equality rights or to two colors are
related if they're not the same and a
homomorphism from a graph to that is a
to coloring of the graph in general
things definable in data are closed
under homomorphisms so it's it makes
sense to talk of the complement so for
any constraint language CSP gamma its
complement is closed under homomorphisms
so it makes sense to ask whether its
complement is definable in data log I
will usually appreciate this to saying
CSP gamma is in data log but I always
understand that means that its
complement is defined about anything at
all okay the data log definable ones are
said to have bounded widths I'm not
going to define I mean what bounded
width is take this as the definition
it's usually it's the same as saying
that this constraint satisfaction
problem is solved by certain local
consistency how rhythms right these are
things which construct assignments to
the variables checking consistency for K
variables at a time and propagating
these these constraints ok so they
really show that they're really checking
that this set of constraints is locally
satisfiable now if the constraint
satisfaction problem have bounded with
its definable in fix point with counting
because fix point with counting is
subsumes data log and so this measure
that i define what i call the counting
width is bounded ok it's kind of
justifies the name bounded with or
that's kind of why I call this counting
width as well in the other direction we
can show that if this thing is not in
data log then this function is unbounded
so actually the only CS the only
constraint satisfaction problems
definable in fixed point with counting
are already definable in data node this
follows from results in these two papers
but you won't find
this stated as such in in either of them
basically the bartow and kazakh papers
establish a certain sufficient algebraic
conditions for this to have bounded
width again I'm not going to formulate
those and what we showed was that in the
absence of these conditions solvability
of systems of linear equations over a
finite field or finite abelian group
generally can be reduced to this by
means of definable reductions and
therefore the undefinable ready carries
over undefined ability in this carries
over to that what I want to point out
now and this is a have to thank Albert
for this that extracting from a paper by
Matt hilaria sorry i misspelled that
actually these definable reductions can
all be made linear so they don't blow up
the size of the structure more than
linearly and so the lower bound on the
counting width of this we establish
carries over linearly to all of these so
CSP gamma has
and if CSP is not a bounded width so if
it is a bounded with this thing is a
constant if it's not a bounded width
there's a linear lower bound on it okay
so I just want to compare this I mean
[ __ ] on mentioned a few times the
farewell party dichotomy conjecture
which says that for every constraint
language either CSP gamez NP or CS
become is np-complete right we don't
know this still we have a definable
ability dichotomy from what I said on
the previous side for every gamma either
this counting with this constant and
then CSP gamma is definable in data log
or this thing is bounded below by a
linear function and it's not definable
even in FPC okay
now all problems in here in number one
rnp every data log definable one is NP
but there are problems in pain in the
second class as well like solvability of
systems of linear equations right they
fall into this class so this is not the
federal artery federal rd dichotomy
right we have everything here is in P
everything that we know to be np-hard
falls in this class but some polynomial
time problems also do okay but this
picture becomes much cleaner when we
look at optimization problems rather
than just decidability problems of CSPs
so i'll write max CSP gamma for the
problem which is the problem of
determining given an instance of CSP
gamma what is the maximum number of
constraints that can be simultaneously
satisfied right it's now an optimization
problem and here you're on topper and
Standish apni have shown a nice
dichotomy if CSP gamma is bounded with
the mac CSP is is solvable in polynomial
time by it's basically in your
programming relaxation i'll define this
in a moment and if it's not a bounded
weights then the problem the
maximization problem is np-hard right so
the decision problem might be polynomial
time but the optimization problem is
np-hard so this is a real dichotomy and
the key the key example keep in mind is
max x or sat given a set of x or sat
clauses right so variables connected by
the x or operator determining its
feasibility is simply solving a system
of linear equations over the two element
field that is decidable but maximizing
the number of constraints that you can
simultaneously satisfies an np-hard
problem and this turns out it's
essentially true for all of you for all
of these all the constraints of
polynomial time which were falling in
the this unbounded class the
corresponding maximization problem is
np-hard ok sort of really nice dichotomy
theorem so now what what can we say
about this
I said the ones are bounded which the
maximization problem is solved by it's
basically in your programming relaxation
what that means is if you have an
instance of this you can turn it into a
linear program so what do we have the
instance consists of a set of variables
V gamma has a domain be and we have a
set of constraints in the incidence of
the form you know people of variables
and a relation R and this is the linear
program I've this is a cut-and-paste job
so I'm written by penguin over there so
I'm relying on you for checking any
errors in here but okay this is a linear
program the variables in the linear
program I want to distinguish on the
variables of the constraint satisfaction
problem is a different thing from the
variables of the linear program the
variables in the linear program are the
lambdas in Muse in this okay there is
one variable mu for each pair V where V
is a variable from that and a where a is
an element of the domain and think of
this as saying we want these what we
want this to take the value one if the
variable V is assigned to the element a
and 0 otherwise okay all we've saying
here is if you sum over all values on
the domain of movie a it's one ok so the
variable little V gets assigned to
something in the domain and the sum of
the these things is one the variable
lambda CD I think of as saying that the
constraint c is satisfied
well the constraints is assigned to the
tuple d from the domain so now this
condition is basically for enforcing the
consistency between those two two two
sets of variables by basically by saying
that this thing really takes the value
you get by assigning the the variables
that appear inside this tuple see so
inside this tuple X to the elements
given by a and this is the maximization
condition which as you maximize the
number of constraints satisfied okay and
we probably haven't got all that but
this we get a linear program from an
instance of CSP and the fact is you need
to add non negative images need to add
not yes so all the way all the variables
are non-negative yeah sure okay now any
zero one solution to this okay is a so
you know well maximizing this the
maximal 0 1 solution to this is exactly
the max ESP of gamma okay but of course
what we get when we solve the linear
program is not an integer solution in
general ah ok I'm looking at the next
slide seems to be further ahead than I
wanted so zero one solution would would
give us what we what we want in general
we get a non integer solution ok that's
the that's a sort of relaxation of the
problem we wanted to solve and I maybe
should go back and say right what this
shows is that if the original CSP is a
bounded width which is the same thing as
say it's definable in data log then this
basic linear programming relaxation will
actually give you the solution to the
optimization problem ok if it's not a
bounded with it won't write the problem
is that be hard you're not going to
solve it just by translating it into a
linear program so what do you do in the
case where in the general case where
this where the original problem is
np-hard
what people do is they consider
tightening zuv this okay through liftin
project hierarchies so the idea is we
have a polytope for an engine for
integer optimization problem we're
really interested in the thing which is
the convex hull of the integer solutions
that's what we really want to get our
hands on well the linear program defines
is some larger polytope and so lift and
project things we get by adding
additional constraints typically the
idea is for tuples of variables in the
original program you add new variables
intended to represent the product and
you add linear constraints or semi
definite constraints to try and enforce
this meaning okay I mean you can't write
down products because you want to keep
it all linear but this is the this is
the general idea so you go to a space of
higher dimension with these additional
variables and the hope is a projecting
it down you get a polytope which is
smaller than the linear programming
relaxation but still contains the convex
hull of the integer solutions you're
interested in as you increase the value
of T you get hierarchies of you know
tighter constraints and people have
looked at various once I'll just mention
these by name I'm not going to define
them share all the atoms lava shriver
Lasserre hierarchy right free increasing
values of T the last is in some sense
the strongest in that the state level of
the lesser hierarchy on a polytope k is
included in those in the corresponding
levels of the others so it's giving you
the tightest approximation ok so the
lesser hierarchy is a hierarchy of semi
definite programs I'm not going to write
down the definition I had the last night
I was sitting with the slides and I call
you know putting down this and I thought
it was just a bit too much so Allah I'll
leave that out let me just state the
following facts about it so we have a
polytope ok we are interested in the
integer points in this polytope
here k star denotes the convex hull of
the integer points this is always
contained in the projection you get from
the teeth level projection back down to
the original variables from the of the
teeth level of the nasarah hark as you
go up the hierarchy right it gets you're
getting smaller convex sets and if you
go up to the level n where n is the
number of variables you started with
then then you actually get projecting
down you do get the convex hull of the
integer points so that's the ultimate
solution ok with this I can now just
State this results this is in a
forthcoming paper with penguin over
there so for each constraint language
gamma and each fixed value of P we can
define an FPC interpretation that takes
an instance of CSP to the teeth level of
the lesser Harkey over blp but what do I
mean by takes it to this basically is in
the instance you define you can define
an explicit representation of the semi
definite program which is the TS level
of the Lasserre hierarchy over over the
basic linear programming relaxation of
this instance so there is an
interpretation that will do this for you
the FPC implementation of the ellipsoid
method I described we shall we can
extend it to semi definite programs so
you know it it works for not just for
solving the linear programs there are
some technical conditions we have to
worry about the full dimensionality but
this can be made to work and the
conclusion is now if the th level of the
Lasserre hierarchy actually solves this
by solves this I mean project it down it
gives you the convex hull of the integer
solutions then T is bounded below by a
linear function of the counting width of
CSP gamma this is simply because you
compose with these FPC interpretations
and they broke blow up the num
variables you need most constant factors
and so if the TF level solves it you can
take this formula that solves the semi
different programs compose it with the
interpretation and get an FPC formula
that solves the maximization problem or
assaults the decision problem on the
original CSP gamma and this is the lower
bound on the number of variables you
need their compulsive liar by the two
constants in the interpretations you get
this but now this function we've shown
exhibits this dichotomy so the
conclusion is if CSP gamma is not a
bounded with again the number of lasalle
levels of the lesser hierarchy you need
is bounded below by a linear function so
you can't do better so for any CSP gamma
either the basic linear programming saw
you know method solves it and you you
know you're in the bounded with case or
you need a linear number of levels to
get to the convex hull of the integer
solutions ok if this is the point where
I wanted to end as I said this is our
recent work will be out of this till I'm
up there presumably this interpretation
can be made uniform in gamma Mt Connie
and well your uniform in gamma and T
well certainly you uniformity I mean ass
got what would it mean to be uniform
yeah I suppose area yes so certainly
there's an algorithm which given gamma
and P will give you the interpretation
in dependence in t is not explanation
so in the number of our obesity it's
even better for me so I mean not a
depend no no the location is only fixed
number of articles the way the state
that is a fixed number of variables for
each 60 right uniformity right so now
you're talking about the number of
variables that appear in the
interpretation and the FPC format are
defining the interpretation ah it is
linear in T I guess
but what do you mean by your from
there's certainly an algorithm which
given gham 90 will give you the
interpretation the number of variables
that appear in the interpretation is
going to be linear in T not as uniform
as I wanted ok right yes now to go back
to look previous topic ah i would have
modeled dueting over the rationals
matrices in some version of final meta
finite was the theory rather than the
way you you put it can you push some of
the result over to the friend right okay
I mean I'm I haven't tried to do that so
anything I say I'm just saying off the
top of my head the so treat with caution
I mean I think writing down this FPC
formula that solves it in that context
would not be difficult I mean one of the
reasons for doing it this way is because
it makes explicit the dependence on the
size of B which is very important in the
ellipsoid method right I mean in general
for linear programming we don't know any
strongly polynomial algorithms right we
don't know any bargains we're taking
arithmetic operation this unit cost our
polynomial time in the size of the
number of variables and because you have
to take polynomial time in the size this
and therefore making this explicit i
think is a more honest representation of
that situation then just hiding this in
an infinite structure but that's as i
said i'm just i haven't really thought
about that
I have a comment to questions if I made
the comment fest there is a very old
result at very cute result by numeral
megiddo like linear programming for the
decision problem for inequalities
welcome polynomial time that's right now
I think this is what you so does they
implies that it is not complete for
polynomial time and the first or there
or even no they're not it follows from
this because because fixed point with
counting is not all of polynomial time
if linear programming was complete under
first order reductions everything in
polynomial time would be in fixed point
with camping which we know is false so
it's a yes it follows it for np-complete
under first-order reductions yes that's
right but of course we don't know any p
complete problems and refers to
reductions because if the world we would
have a logic for people but this linear
programming is not such yes please help
me understand decorum right here so
because CSP is not a bounded with mm-hmm
we know but by the top perceive me that
that sees the maxi space and Bihar right
that's right so what but this relaxation
yeah so so the idea is this you um
actually maybe let me go back here
that's right it's an exponent as the
semi national programs are exponential
in the level so the teeth level is of
size exponential in T the body uniform
well he in fact pub probably yes because
because the th level is of size n to the
T you need linear and T variables to
express it to construct it yeah good
point yes well good okay last question
if I may so we know that max ESP gamma
mm-hmm the class max SMP because of Papa
dear Indiana khakis it's not okay
proximo constant erection problems so
right this is another big success of
this case complexity rang my problems
tells us something about the approximate
really different problems yet well for
the last 10 years people have worked
very hard to determine the threshold
what works mobility know the information
about this coming week there was
something about the threshold view IIIi
don't really know because in fact you
know I mean even in the context of
lesser our key people have offered and
looked at these as giving approximate
solution and but the criterion we were
using here is the rather stronger one at
what level do you get exactly the convex
hull of the integer solutions which is
not quite the same thing so I casa la
gaveta keep Dan is to defend the threats
was multiple unique games context right
right right right be nice to see if you
can be okay yeah I just have to say I
don't know directly
be within the context of this MVC
framework essentially giving an analog
of an answer to the unique games
conjecture in that context in the sense
that you know you know they they want to
show that that is at be hard but you're
okay you have a surrogate for that DC
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a that's a
very outstanding open problem whether
the Las a hierarchy refuge taken against
projector oh so throw a cel hierarchy is
raised i handed fitting out what is i
mean they had item in a few different it
that maybe five levels of the hierarchy
gives you an end to the five algorithm
so a 50-unit games going on oh oh i see
so you're saying that can you go to that
last time so you're saying that in the
last one then says the connection
between the listener are key and this
now says refuting it in the context of
FBC oh no so this connection is
specifically do four things at the form
ax ESP exact its razor okay yeah so
there is still a possibility of doing
what I said set just in it within this
MVC framework saying but you know you
can't turn unique games conjectured on
the real time and that kind of acting as
a surrogate for you know what I need to
be
another okay Hank yeah we need to take a
break now thank you